all righty did George HW Bush sexually
harass actresses and wise Mark Halperin
in the news and also why was the left
actually cheering in abortion yesterday
not just saying it was okay cheering it
openly plus we're gonna talk about the
divisions inside the Republican Party
our Steve Bannon and Donald Trump really
in charge of the Republican Party now
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show so many interesting things to talk
about today it's not often that we get a
news cycle as interesting as this one
and we'll talk about all of them but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so if you
have not yet heard the market may be
over inflated you should always
diversify and have at least a little bit
of your assets in precious metals
because it provides a good solid base
from which to work that doesn't mean
every dollar should be in gold but it
doesn't mean that some of your money
should be in precious metals as a hedge
against inflation in the stock market
inflation in the monetary supply as a
hedge against inflation in the real
estate market and that's why I trust the
folks over at Birch gold group Birch
gold group has a long-standing track
record of continued success with
thousands of satisfied clients countless
five-star reviews an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau contact them
right now to receive a free information
kit on physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16 page kit showing how
you can also move your money out of a
401k or IRA into a precious metals 401k
or IRA you can go and check it out at
birchgold.com slash Ben birchgold.com
slash Ben ask all your questions make
sure that you know what you're doing and
then when you're ready to to get those
questions answered and and invest a
little bit in precious metals talk to my
friends over at birchgold.com slash Ben
slash Ben's so they know that we sent
you okay so we begin today with this
story that has been making the rounds on
Twitter and in the news that George HW
Bush supposedly sexually harassed some
actresses so let me give you the
information then I will and then I'll
explain my my perspective on this so
basically this week there's an actress
named Heather Lynch whose most famously
on turn where she played Abigail and she
accused former President George HW Bush
of sexual harassment in 2014 when Bush
was 91 and already in a wheelchair Bush
apologized through his spokesman on
Wednesday morning saying that President
Bush would never intentionally caused
anyone distress and he sincerely
apologizes if his attempt at humor
offended miss Lynn and then they
released another statement and here's
the statement that they released ok
quote an agent
three President Bush has been confined
to a wheelchair for roughly five years
so his arm falls on the lower waist of
people with whom he takes pictures to
try to put people at ease the president
routinely tells the same joke and on
occasion he has patted women's rears and
what he intended to be a good-natured
manner some obscene and his innocent
others clearly viewed as inappropriate
to anyone he has offended President Bush
apologizes most sincerely so dead spin
of course doing the hard yeoman Lee work
of reporting found out that the dirty
joke that Lindh referred to in her
statement went something like this
apparently a tipster past word about the
heather Lynn incident to Deadspin we
were told that Bush had during a photo
op groped her and told her that his
favorite magician was David Copperfield
while fondling her which I mean okay hey
that's that's really is that him in any
case so here that there was another
actress who came out and she said that
he's done the same thing where's this
actress named Jordana grolnick and she
was working at a main production of
Hunchback of Notre Dom when Bush
attended and she said we all circled
around him and Barbara for a photo I was
right next to him he reached his right
hand around to my behind and as we
smelled for the photo he asked the group
do you want to know who my favorite
magician is and as I felt my his hands
iggins my flesh she said David coppaFeel
okay so they're the reason I'm smiling
is because this is all ridiculous okay
so they because it's ridiculous in one
sense and not ridiculous in the other I
mean just the image of a 93 year old
president shouting David Copperfield as
you grab someone is a little bit
humorous in any case there there are a
couple things about this that I think
are worthy of note one is President HW
Bush is is George HW Bush now in the
throes of dementia so he has Parkinson's
disease there are there are associations
between Parkinson's disease and dementia
over the past eight years or so I've
heard from people he has been slipping a
little bit has President HW Bush and so
if you go to an age old old age home
people act inappropriately all the time
now there's two type of old people who
act inappropriately some who are
actually suffering from dementia and
some who just feel like screw it F it to
life I'm old I can do it I want if this
is the latter then I'm not gonna make
excuses for this behavior because here's
the reality if my wife were groped on
the behind while some old guy shouted
David Copperfield I would not be a happy
camper
and I assume neither would she now this
idea that it's okay because Bush is
older because he was a war hero I don't
buy that if it's okay it's only okay
because he was you know
in the throes of dementia right if you
want to say that he's not responsible
for his actions then that's something I
buy but this idea that it's not some
form of sexual harassment for him to do
that I don't buy if he is doing this out
of his own free will and volition and
there's no mental attitude and I will
give you the case in point bringing back
our old campaign shoe right I use to
have a shoe on the desk or put it on the
other foot if this were Bill Clinton I
think Bill Clinton grabbed a woman's
butt and shout at David Copperfield
everyone on the right would go nuts and
say right because this is Bill Clinton
so there people will say right because
Bill Clinton has a record of this HW
doesn't that's true
but that's why I suggest that maybe we
ought to hold off until there's more
information on exactly what hwn ttle
state is but people who are making light
of this I don't think that it's
something that ought to be completely
made light of or dismissed out of hand
and people are saying that Heather Lin
should be ashamed for even saying
anything about it I just don't again I'm
really more torn on this than I think a
lot of other people are on the right
okay and maybe that's an unpopular point
of view but frankly I don't really care
I think it's inappropriate for guys to
grab girls behind and shout cop-a-feel
whether they're 23 or 93 if they're can
in control of their actions and just
because you've done some good things in
your life doesn't mean everything
becomes good there's one of my chief
complaints about how people gauge human
beings I'll say he's a good man and then
by saying he's a good man they mean
everything that he does forever we have
to see is good good people do bad things
good people do stupid things right
overall the judgment can be the person's
good and the person can Dill's do still
do some dumb things or still do some
some bad things in any case this is case
in point of sexual harassment number one
from today's from today's news
case in point number two is one that the
left will immediately say is not sexual
harassment in any way and that's because
the person at issue is Ellen DeGeneres
and Ellen DeGeneres is a famous in well
beloved Hollywood lesbian so the reason
that that is relevant her sexuality is
because Ellen DeGeneres tweeted this out
yesterday this is a tweet of her on Katy
Perry's birthday and it's a picture of
Ellen DeGeneres staring directly into
Katy Perry's cleavage from about 6
inches away as her partner Portia de
Rossi laughs next to her I think is
Portia de Rossi correct I'm pretty sure
and and then Katy Perry is kind of
smiling into the camera slightly
awkwardly and it says happy birthday
Katy Perry it's time to bring out the
big balloons right a direct reference to
her breasts now let me just suggest if
any man tweeted out this exact photo
this exact photo
if Ellen's head or Harvey Weinstein's
head we would be talking about this was
more evidence of sexual harassment in
Hollywood Ellen DeGeneres is a very very
powerful host and the fact that Katy
Perry seems to be smiling here is not
the issue right I mean there are plenty
of pictures where Harvey Weinstein is
posing with smiling women who he
sexually harassed or sexually assaulted
the fact is that there's a double
standard with how we treat these
situations and as I have been now saying
for weeks we need some sort of singular
standard as to what constitutes
appropriate behavior and what does not
Ellen DeGeneres is a lesbian which means
that this is you know hurt acting upon
objects of her sexual desire if a man
did the same thing we would be saying
this is totally inappropriate how dare
he and it doesn't matter the Katy Perry
smiling it just shows how toxic
masculinity has infused everyone the
whole point here is the double standard
and double standard applies everywhere
Mark Halperin it just was essentially
fired from NBC News
he said he resigned her took time off to
spend more time with his with his
genitals but in any case Mark Halperin
the accusations are that he allegedly
sexually assaulted up to five women
sexually harassed her assaulted up to
five women that he would push them up
against the wall groped them press his
genitals against them
this is Mark Halperin the guy Road Game
Change very famous reporter he's on the
NBC News every day has has talked about
sexual assault in the most in the most
indignant of terms sexual assault is his
horrible sexual harassment is horrible
and then meanwhile in the back room he's
grabbing he's grabbing the interns
apparently this goes to show you also
the the not only do we have a double
standard with regard to people we like
with double standard with regard to
ourselves the stuff that we do we human
beings have unique capacity to do this
we can engage in many of the sins that
we condemn other people for and the mark
of a good human being is that you think
enough about this to think whether in
fact you are upholding the standard that
you seek to promulgate that you're
upholding the standard that you seek to
push if you're not doing that then we
all need to do better and I think we can
all do better on on these scores but the
reason I'm pointing out these three
different scenarios the HW the ellen
degeneres and the mark halperin
situations is because these double
standards have been in place for a very
long time and we need to decide as a
society what sort of behavior we are
willing to accept
I think the behavior should be this men
do not touch women without their
permission that's the behavior right
we're done here and it's not the same
thing if a man asks
to a bar it's not the same thing if a
man says that a girl is beautiful today
it's not the same thing if a man says
that she that he likes a girl's dress
okay a woman's dress not the same thing
at all we need to make some actual
separations here but instead what I feel
like this is devolved into is now we're
just as usual conversations in America
has evolved into who's the victim today
and then we all come out and say it's
terrible that person was victimized and
then we said no standard by which we can
determine whether someone is victim or
not until they proclaim themselves a
victim at which point we say that our
victim right so if we had found out the
HW Bush Heather Lin thing just through a
third party source not through Heather
Lind
then we would have had to decide in
societies there's something okay or not
she declared that she was offended
therefore it was bad if she had declared
that she was not offended then it would
have been fine hey action is not
subjective when it comes to societal
standards it's not subjective you don't
get to decide whether an activity is
good or bad for me right I as a member
of society determine whether it's an
activity is good or bad and I'm getting
kind of tired of this routine where
something is not harassment so long as
I'm not offended but it is harassment if
I am offended we're gonna need to draw
some lines if we actually want to
enforce those lines I want to talk a
little bit about a little bit about
another story that's that's pretty
devastating out of the state of Texas
yesterday and then I want to get into
what I really want to talk about today
at length which is the split inside the
Republican Party but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at da
Vinci so in today's digital world there
are a lot of people who don't even have
offices office buildings and so they've
been doing meetings at coffee shops or
expensive hotel conference room so you
don't have to do that anymore da Vinci
is a fantastic service
I know because we've used it in
Sacramento we used it when I traveled to
when I traveled to New York I believe
the Utah sorry I travel so much and we
use da Vinci all the time da Vinci is
great because da Vinci basically allows
you to book a conference room and there
will be an assistant there to help you
and they'll bring you water and coffee
it's it's just like having an office
building anytime you want it at very
inexpensive prices they provide you
instant access to over 5,000 incredibly
affordable meeting rooms and well-known
office locations in virtually every city
and they make it really easy you search
you book you meet and again it comes
fully staffed equipped with all the
latest tech plus high speed internet and
it's super affordable we're not talking
about $500 rooms we're talking about
things and we got one in Sacramento for
like
forty bucks or something and we were
able to do the show from there this is
right before my vacation we were able to
show from there there was an assistant
there who is bringing me water during
the show so I didn't deciding go dry you
know that The Da Vinci is just fantastic
whether you need a day office or a
conference from a boardroom or a
training space they have what you need
to make it your next business meeting a
success fortune 500 companies daily wire
we's da Vinci book your space now it's a
Vinci meeting.com slash been da Vinci
meeting.com slash pen and your first
hour is on them that's da Vinci
meeting.com slash been your first hour
is free terms and conditions do apply
for details see da Vinci meeting.com
slash been hold your next meeting in the
best possible place without spending a
ton of money to Vinci meeting.com slash
pennies that slash pen so your first
hours free and that they know and that
we sent you okay so in others in other
news that was making a splash yesterday
the the Court of Appeals in the District
of Columbia the the DC Court of Appeals
ruled that a seventeen-year-old illegal
immigrant could abort her baby in the
United States without going through the
the hoops that Texas law requires so
here is the story the seventeen year old
girl jumped the border while she was
pregnant and then decided to obtain an
abortion under Texas law minors have to
receive parental consent or judicial
waiver for an abortion and Texas bans
abortion after week 20 so the clock was
sort of ticking here she wanted to get
an abortion before week 20 so that it
would be legal even though you know she
jumped the border illegally and while
the young woman ended up receiving a
judicial waiver she then had to schedule
a sonogram and consult and a
consultation with a doctor which is also
under Texas law they say you have to
actually look at what the baby is before
you kill the baby so that you are not
abiding by the mythology that this is
just a cluster of cells I mean this is
what a 16 week old baby looks like okay
when we talked about she aborted a 16
week old baby yes yesterday this is what
a 16 week old baby looks like do we have
that graphic yeah this is what I mean
it's a human right I mean I've seen em
the ultrasounds of my own children at
this age to pretend this is anything
other than a human baby is just to be
scientifically illiterate and also block
yourself from basic fact in any case she
was she was kept in the detention center
so she couldn't go to her appointment so
she sued and the government contended
that she had options for leaving federal
custody right she could just go home
right the Coogee they could deport her
they could send her back to her home
country or she could find a sponsor you
know she could find somebody who's
willing to take her in that would then
be her legal guardian the legal guardian
would give permission and then she'd be
good to go but the idea that Texas law
would have to change because she's an
illegal immigrant that something Texas
wasn't willing to do so the DC Court of
Appeals instead ruled that this woman
had a right to an abortion the woman
immediately headed off to an abortion
clinic before it could be appealed and
she went and had the baby killed she
said people I don't even know are trying
to make me change my mind I made my
decision and that is between me and God
again abortion is not just a matter
between you and God it's a matter as to
which society has a say just as if you
were to murder a baby after birth we all
have a say in that that's not between
you and God that's between you the
babies society and God right we all have
a say in this one the part of this
that's really horrifying is not just you
know a girl having an abortion at
sixteen weeks which is inherently
horrifying from any view that places the
sanctity of human life at the center
it's horrifying the way that some people
are left responded so the ACLU tweeted
this out they tweeted breaking justice
prevailed today for Jane Doe she was
able to get an abortion early this
morning hashtag justice for Jane
yay dead baby justice for Jane this is
one movement that I've seen on the left
that really is quite horrifying
this idea that abortion is not something
to be ashamed of or to be morally
conflicted about it's something to
celebrate that her obtaining an abortion
is a victory for justice in the United
States certainly not justice for the
baby okay a baby at 16 weeks is about
the size of an avocado it's four and a
half inches long head to rump about
three and a half ounces the legs are
developed the head is more erect they
started growing toenails the heart is
pumping about 25 quarts of blood every
day okay baby has an independent blood
type has an independent DNA and you saw
the picture I mean the baby's baby but
the left celebrates nonetheless treating
the u.s. as an abortion Haven should be
something of which we are deeply ashamed
and the idea that you come to the United
States and therefore you have a right to
an abortion and even if you're here
illegally is is pretty astonishing to me
and should be astonishing I think to a
lot of other folks okay so now I want to
get to the topic that has preoccupied me
this morning there's an article over The
Daily Beast that I find quite
fascinating about the future of the
Republican Party in the aftermath of
Jeff Flake in the aftermath of bob
Corker
the aftermath of all of these people who
are who are leaving the Republican Party
or retiring or suggesting that it's the
end of the Republican Party and all the
rest of it one of the one of the
theories that has been out there is that
Steve Bannon and Donald Trump are now
solely in charge of the Republican Party
and that these people cannot be stopped
that basically they run the place so say
I'm Stein I so when soup saying I'm I
think insects pronounce and in Lachlan
Marquis have an article today out at the
Daily Beast and it says establishment
Republicans agree Steve Bannon is
kicking our ass and say in the
escalating war within the Republican
Party there's one fact that both sides
increasingly agree on the forces being
ushered by Steve Bannon are currently
winning the former White House chief
strategist and chairman of Breitbart
news has pledged to purge the GOP of its
squishy establishment members a
delineation he said extends to everyone
in the Senate saved Ted Cruz which is
ironic considering how Breitbart went
after Ted Cruz in the primaries so far
this cycle even his critics concede he's
encountered like push back and then rick
wilson who is an anti-trump GOP
strategist he compared ban him to Isis
leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi which is a
wild overstatement and say he's funded
by billionaires has a shallow catchy
much a message that appeals to
marginally educated fanatics and the
like and the idea here is that Bannon is
now the force inside the Republican
Party that if you oppose Trump you
cannot survive on anything not just you
oppose him generally you oppose him on
any issue you will not survive and been
and will lead the charge so I'm trying
to break down this theory because I'm
trying to see what exactly is true and
what is not here number one there seems
to be an idea after the philosophical
Bandhan ISM and philosophical trumpism
are on the rise this is the nationalist
populist movement we've heard so much
about that says that we have to close
all our borders and we can't engage in
trade anymore and that immigrants are
not welcome here anymore and that we
ought to spend enormous amounts of money
on public works projects and all of this
right this is the nationalist populist
sort of far-right european movement and
this is what's on the rise in the united
states we are told i do not see the
evidence of that i don't see the
evidence of that the reason i don't see
the evidence of that is there is a poll
that's out today from the from pew
or rather it's sorry yes Pew Research
Center and they do a political typology
looking at Fisher
on the right and they break down
conservatives into several different
groups okay they call their their core
conservatives country first
conservatives markets market skeptic
Republicans and new eera enterprisers so
core conservatives are basically
described as people who believe that the
future of the country is is bright and
that involvement in global economy is
good because it provides the us with new
markets and opportunities for growth and
they believe that in get that
immigration is generally a good because
it's providing more people for the
economy to work with and they believe
that the government has already done
enough on environmental regulations and
they've believed that the United States
has basically achieved racial parity at
least in terms of law you know this is
sort of the core conservative message
that by far represents the largest share
of politically engaged Republicans forty
three percent of politically engaged
Republicans are core conservatives I am
a core conservative I know because they
have a little quiz over a Pew Research
and you can tell which one you are I am
a core conservative okay so I am with
the majority or at least the plurality
of the of the politically engaged
Republicans next to come what they call
the country first conservatives these
are people who are unhappy with the
nation's course they're highly critical
of immigration and they're wary of US
global involvement so this would be the
nationalist populist group it's a much
smaller segment of the base according to
Pew Research a much smaller segment of
the base then there's the market skeptic
Republicans and these are people who say
banks and financial institutions have a
positive effect on the way things are
going in the country so these would be
the these are P weather sorry the
opposite most of them say that banks and
other financial institutions have a
negative effect on the way things are
going in the country so this would be
the populist okay there's a very small
group and then finally you have the New
Era enterprisers who are sort of open
borders open trade and they say
everything is great but they also want
more regulations of the environment this
would basically be the Jeff Flake wing
of the party so when you break it down
what you see is that by far the largest
group by far the largest group are
people core the core conservatives right
the 43% of all politically engaged
Republicans and then much smaller
percentage our market skeptic
Republicans who would be the nationalist
populist and country first conservatives
and then the new era enterprisers so
where is the shift for Trump right if
the idea was that President Trump was
going to be the the guy
assured in a new era of philosophy or
that Bannon ISM was on the rise there's
not much to actually suggest that's true
there's really not much to suggest
that's true right instead what it looks
like is that core conservatives still
are the moving force inside the party
and core conservatives along with the
new era and surprises along with Jeff
Flake would represent 59% of the
Republican Party right that is a solid
majority those numbers really haven't
changed so trumpism and Bandhan ISM are
not a thing right there's no
philosophically consistent trumpism
abandon ISM the other proof of this is
the fact that all of the candidates that
Bannon himself has approved of don't
agree with each other right so there's
this idea that that bannon's philosophy
is now ascendant in the Republican Party
that's not true okay Roy Moore has very
little in common with the ante Tarkanian
the guy who who Bannon has endorsed in
the Nevada Senate run they both have
very little in common with Ted Cruz who
apparently Bannon likes they have very
little in common with Kelly Ward Roy
Moore is sort of more in line with Kelly
Ward than Danny Tarkanian is there's a
congressman named Michael Grimm out in
New York is pretty socially liberal as
far as I can see and Bannon has endorsed
him none of these people have anything
in common right they're all over the
place so why is been and endorsing them
I'll explain in just a second what this
suggested that Bannon is meant trumpism
are not a philosophy driving the
Republican Party this is why I objected
to jeff flakes analysis yesterday in
which Jeff Flake suggested that it's
hard for a pro FreeMarkets
Pro immigration Republicans get elected
that is not true
59% of Republicans agree with that basic
principle according to this pupil so no
that's not true okay so maybe if it's
not the Bandon ISM as a philosophy or
trumpism as a philosophy driving the
future of the Republican it's Trump or
Bandhan themselves and here again I
disagree the reason I disagree is
because Trump went to war on behalf of
Luther strange in Alabama and Luther
strange lost Steve Bannon tried to take
credit for Luther strange losing but the
fact is Luther strange was going to lose
anyway because Roy Moore was the
outsider and Roy Moore was way more well
known than Steve Bannon was in Alabama
Steve Bannon is an afterthought in
Alabama and the fact is that Stevens
Breitbart didn't even back Roy Moore in
the original primary in Alabama they
backed mo Brooks who finished third so
this idea that Bannon has some sort of
outsized influence as a human being like
as a person like he's the leader of a
movement it's not true he's a lot of
money from the Mercer's behind him but
he's not somebody who's actually leading
the movement he's not somebody who's
crafting the movement around him and he
is the great leader again there's not a
lot of evidence to back any of this
there's not a lot of evidence to back
any of this so you know so what exactly
is going on what exactly is going on
here I'll explain in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blinds.com
so there's one part of your house that
you probably don't think much about
because it's just been on your windows
since you bought the place and you
haven't thought about replacing it and
that is your blinds but a nice set of
blinds can make your house look a lot
better
right you know it because every time you
look at somebody's crappy blinds you
think god they updated this place since
the 1970s blinds calm makes it really
easy for you so if you're not sure what
you want or even where to start with
blinds calm you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture specific rooms they'll send
you free samples to make sure that the
material matches what it looks like
online and the best part is if you
accidentally miss measure or pick the
wrong color
blinds calm will redo it for free so you
screw up it's your fault doesn't matter
blinds.com will still cover it
they made it super easy for you and for
a limited time you get 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben we're working with blinds
comm and the Shapiro home right now a
bunch of old old screens that we don't
like and so we're using blinds comm
right now for a limited time 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
that promo code Ben again that's faux
wood blinds cellular shades roller
shades and more blinds comm promo code
Ben rules and restrictions apply use
that promo code Ben for 20% off and also
so that they know that we sent you that
always helps us okay so if it's not the
trumpism and Bannen ism our dominance in
a sentence if it's not that Trump
himself is the moving force in the
Republican Party or Bannon isn't the
moving force in the Republican Party
then what exactly is going on why are
Trump and Bannon important figures why
are we even talking about them well I
think it has much more to do with the
attitude than anything else what exactly
unifies all of the candidates that
bannon's endorsing what exactly unifies
all of the candidates that Trump has
backed what unifies the support for
Trump it's all attitude
it's a feeling from Republicans the
Republicans have been squishes for too
long that Jeff Flake was a squish and he
was more intent on earning strange new
respect from the left then he wasn't
actually fighting for conservative
principles this is why the right is a
lot more tolerant to Ben Sasse who's
very anti Trump than it is a
Jeff Flake right SAS is widely perceived
as somebody who's actually conservative
because he is he has the third most
conservative voting record in the United
States Senate but we're willing to
overlook you know a lot of his anti
Trump rhetoric at least from supporters
are because he is very conservative and
because he's shown that he's willing to
fight the left if you're willing to
fight the left then you can fight Trump
too when Trump does something wrong but
if you're not willing to fight the left
and it seems like all of your criticisms
into is reserved for Trump people assume
bad motivations and I think not entirely
without cause not entirely without cause
the truth is that the Republican Party
has been motivated by an
anti-establishment anger since 2009 long
before anyone knew about Trump long
before anyone knew about ban and no one
cared about Trump Trump was just some
guy to The Apprentice and battle is just
some schmuck who walked around Los
Angeles pretending he was important
right Steve Danon was not a thing in
2009 in 2009 the movement started to
cast out these Republican establishment
types who apparently had caved to the
Democrats right the Tea Party was
launched in opposition to Republican
establishment types Mitch McConnell was
already a curse word in 2009 2010 among
Republicans he was hey this is just a
fact the Dave brat won defeated Eric
Cantor and I think it was 2010
specifically because of this right Dave
brat defeated I want to see when he was
elected so sorry I guess he was elected
in 2014
Dave brat defeated his the incumbent
Eric Cantor in 2014 and a huge shock
because this had already been a
burgeoning movement Trump wasn't running
been and wasn't important at that point
so what exactly happened here the answer
is there's a lot of anger there's a lot
of anger and some of it is is proper and
some of it is correct but some of it is
not right some of this is some of this
is not and this is the problem what is
driving the Republican bus right now is
the anger okay the elephant has always
been anger the elephant the room has
always been anger some of that time it's
been directed in proper directions
against Obamacare against stimulus
packages against establishment
Republicans who are weak but some of the
time the person who has hopped up atop
the elephant is leading the anger
elephant in the wrong direction and the
anger elephant is basically willing to
go wherever there is the most anger it
feeds off of anger now I wrote a piece
this morning based on a George RR
Martin's short story this george RR
martin short story which i really
like it was it was a short story called
the monkey treatment and the monkey
treatment is about this guy in in penny
Dorchester is this obese fat guy and he
wants to get skinny and one day in a
restaurant he runs into a guy he used to
go to a basically a Jenny Craig program
with name Henry Henry Maroney and Henry
Maroney is looking skinny he's a little
bit gaunt but it looks like he's lost a
ton of weight and so Kenny Dorchester
asks Henry Maroney where'd you do this
he's well you know as this place we can
get the monkey treatment and so and so
Kenny goes there and the monkey
treatment is exactly what it sounds like
it is literally a monkey it turns out to
an invisible monkey he's literally a
monkey that jumps on your back and then
whenever you try to eat something it
grabs the food out of your hand and eats
it and over the course of the story the
monkey continues to grow bigger and
bigger it's a horror story the monkey
continues to grow bigger and bigger and
bigger insults its 800-pound gorilla on
top of on top of his back Kenny
dorchester has lost the weight but now
he's basically reduced to nothing but
skin and bones in the very end of the
story he ends up basically throwing
himself from the eighth story of a
building he survives by crushing the
monkey on his back and then he goes
right back to eating enormous amounts of
food right this is this is the basic
idea the reason that I cite this story
is because I think that's sort of what
the anger monkey has become on the right
I've said for many for for many years
that I think one of the problems with
anger is that anger has to be properly
directed righteous indignation is a
useful thing and righteous indignation
is something worthwhile Andrew Breitbart
wrote a book by that name being
indignant being angry because something
has angered you is worthwhile if it has
a specific target but what is not
worthwhile what is not useful is the is
this misdirected anger at anything and
everything and whoever seems the
angriest who ever projects anger the
best becomes your ally right if you if
you project a swagger a machismo then
somehow this is going to mean that you
are a bigger fighter right this is why
the he fights thing worked for President
Trump it worked for President Trump
because he was he was pushing that anger
and so it was easy for him to hop atop
the anger elephant but if the anger
elephant is is if Trump goes up against
the anger elephant the anger elephant
wins which is exactly what happened in
Alabama if Bannon goes up against the
anger elephant the anger elephant wins
Bannon does have a gift and so does
Trump for channeling the anger elephant
but they are not in charge of the anger
elephant any more than the rider is in
charge of the elephant of the Alpha
really wants to buy him the biggest
problem for conservative Republicans who
oppose Trump is that they have to
acknowledge that a lot of the anger is
justified and then they have to channel
that anger in positive directions they
can't just say all anger is wrong
because that's not true and they can't
just say all anger is right because
that's not true either that's say some
anger is right and some anger is wrong
and here's how I propose channeling our
outrage and here's why the outrage is
justified right the outrage is justified
when you're talking about things against
which is justified it is not justified
just as a generalized sense of grievance
and if we don't realize that then the
anger is gonna take over the party and
destroy the party the anger is going to
reduce conservatism this is how
Republicans treated anger in 2009 we
felt like the Republican Party was fat
it was morbidly obese it was lazy it
didn't fight and so he took the anger
Monken we put it right on the back of
the of the obese Republican Party and
the anger monkey immediately started
eating all of the goods and that was
good for a while right we were we were
taking away Democratic power all across
the aisle across the state legislatures
we weren't in 13 governorships we were
winning a thousand seats across the
across the country were winning the
house who weren't in the Senate all of
that was good but there came a point at
which we stopped depriving the anger
monkey of food right we just kept
feeding it and the anger monkey just
kept eating and now we are being reduced
to the sad sack of bones conservatism is
at least when it goes up against the
anger monkeys the anger monkey has to be
deprived when the anger monkey is not
correct and that requires us to use our
reason and not just our amygdala became
emotional response is not enough anymore
at this point okay so I do want to talk
at length about the latest on the
dossier the Trump Russia dossier that
people are going nuts over but first I
have to say goodbye over on Facebook if
you want to subscribe $9.99 a month will
get you a subscription to daily wire.com
when you do that you get the rest of the
show on video live which is pretty
awesome you also get the rest of the
Andrew Klavan show live on video you
also get the rest of Michael nolza show
live on video that's coming up at 12:30
today Clavin is at 10:30 today and you
also get to be harder for the mailbag so
tomorrow it's re Thursday so tomorrow is
the mailbag if you want to ask questions
live to me and make your life a thousand
times better it's just gonna cost you
$9.99 a month or if you want the annual
subscription then you get this the very
grandest in all of beverage vessels he
left his tears ha
called tumblr perfect for any liquid but
apparently it's I've heard that it is
apparently terrific and holding salty
water so leftist tears hydrocal mug you
get that with the with the $99 a year
subscription the annual subscription
plus we would appreciate it if you go
and subscribe to our YouTube channel our
YouTube channel has not just the rest of
the show doesn't it just have the show
on audio and the beginning on video but
our YouTube channel also allows us to
release all sorts of new videos you have
a funny one coming out tomorrow right
the stranger things videos coming out
tomorrow so we have a stranger things
parody that's coming out tomorrow so
you're gonna want to check that out go
subscribe over at youtube or listen
later at iTunes or SoundCloud leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest and fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so with all this said about the anger
monkey what is the proper angle to take
with regard to President Trump the
proper angle to take with regard to
President Trump is exactly the same
angle that I've used with every other
president and that I used for Trump
during the campaign it is the good Trump
bad Trump model when Trump does bad
things you criticize him heartily and
when he does good things you praise him
heartily but I'll tell you two things
that you don't do you don't do the
everything trumpet has ever done is bad
because that's not true because that's
not how human beings work and you know
do the everyone should just shut up and
ignore what Trump is doing because
that's not right either when Trump does
something wrong then he should be hit
for it so here are the two things you
should not do the first is Jeff Flake
basically saying despairing of the party
I can't win a primary because I'm too
anti Trump because I am - glorious -
wonderful
the reason Jeff Flake can't win a
primary is because he's perceived as an
establishment squish because he moved to
the left upon being elected to the
Senate and then he spent the rest of his
time bashing Trump without ever once
lifting a finger against the left and so
people perceived him as a squish but
that's not the way he's gonna play it
well the bottom line is if I were to run
a campaign that I could be proud of and
where I didn't have to cozy up to the
president and his positions or his
behavior
I could not win in a Republican primary
that's the bottom line it's it's it's
not that you have to just be with the
President on policy you can't question
his behavior and still be a Republican
in good standing apparently in a
Republican primary I don't see the
evidence for that at all
I really don't Jeff Flake was again
really implies down to 18% approval
rating
he was really unpopular upon being
elected so that's just not factually
accurate but this idea that the
Republican Party has to be thrown under
the bus in order to save Trump that
something Trump wants you to believe in
it's something Jeff Flake wants you to
believe
I don't think it's something that's true
the other thing you shouldn't do is what
Ted Cruz did here really I like senator
Cruz but when Ted Cruz says you know
everybody in Congress should just shut
up and stop talking about Trump we've
got a job to do when Trump says bad
things you have to speak out because you
still have moral credibility on your own
right you are still an individual with
the capacity to say when bad things
happen regardless from from whom these
bad things spring here's Cruz making
this point well look I think everybody
should stop bickering and engaging in
just personal attacks I think
should focus on doing our job that's
what my focus is I'll say everyday
walking down the hall of the Capitol
that there is a swarm of reporters like
locust that's endzone and they want to
comment on so one so said this so-and-so
said this and it and it's like you're
back in junior high I really don't care
who passed a note to the cute girls and
pigtails we've got a job to do dammit
and and so all of this nonsense
I got nothing to say and everyone shut
up and do your job okay look you should
have something to say when the nonsense
actually impacts policy there's some
times when it's just Trump mouthing off
about bob Corker or something and
they're like really that's between them
but when Trump says stuff that's that's
actually egregious when he attacks a
Goldstar Widow for example you know then
then you should sound off and if you're
not sounding off I think you're doing
something wrong just from a moral point
of view I don't think the Republican
Party opposes that I don't think most
conservatives oppose that I think most
conservatives just want to know that you
are not more interested in tearing down
Trump than you are in fighting the left
that's all most conservatives want to
know that's all and if you're willing to
do that I think you want a primary but
if you are more concerned with tearing
down Trump personally than you are with
fighting bad stuff where wherever you
see it whether it's the left or Trump
then I think that you're it's gonna be
hard for you to buy credibility in a
Republican primary okay so in other news
an FEC complaint has now been filed
against the Hillary Clinton campaign
this is according to media I the DNC and
Hillary Clinton's campaign violated
campaign finance laws by failing to
accurately disclose payments related to
the so-called Trump dossier the
nonpartisan campaign Legal Center said
in a complaint filed today with the
Federal Election Commission according to
recent reports in the media marquel is
who also serves as the Clinton campaign
lawyer paid Oppo research from fusion
GPS to produce the dossier which exposed
alleged connections between Trump and
the Russian government
it also contains salacious allegations
about Trump's personal escapades so
there are a couple issues that still
have to be resolved as I said yesterday
about the Trump dossier in order for
Hilary and her team to have done
anything deeply wrong okay number one
you can pay for Oppo research number one
you can you you can pay for Apple
Research people do it all the time there
are two questions one why did they lie
about it right why did Mark Elias said
that they had nothing to do with paying
for the Oppo research
number two did Hillary Clinton or
on her team know that Christopher steel
was being funneled information by
members of the Russian government the
dossier itself contains all of this okay
the dossier itself byron york points
this house describes one source as quote
a senior Russian Foreign Ministry figure
it describes another source is a form of
top-level Russian intelligence officer
still active inside the Kremlin dossier
source II is a senior Russian financial
official so this does raise questions as
to whether Christopher steel was
basically acting as go-between for
Russian Intel that was trying to dig up
dirt on Trump and then pass it through
the election system in an attempt to
screw up the election system if Hillary
knew that was the case then it looks a
lot more like the Donald Trump jr.
situation right the Donald Trump jr.
situation was somebody emailed him said
I have a lawyer from the Russian
government who wants to talk to you
because Russian wants to help and Trump
jr. says sounds great maybe they have
Oppo that was basically the story and it
turns out the Oppo didn't pass hands
nothing may have come of it but it
showed Trump juniors willingness to work
with members people who are close to the
Russian government in order to do this
it is possible that's what happened here
if Christopher Steele was working with
the Russian government to come up with
this information we don't know that and
we don't know that Hillary Clinton knew
that was true even if she knew that the
dossier existed so those are questions
that still have to be answered but the
idea that that there was some sort of
collusion on the other side going on is
not as implausible as it was four days
ago let's let's put it this way
and Trump makes exactly that point here
is President Trump saying the hoax is
all turned around now they lost it by a
lot they didn't know what to say so they
made up the whole Russia hoax now it's
turning out that the hoax has turned
around and you look at what's happened
with Russia and you look at the uranium
deal and you look at the fake dossier so
that's all turned around okay so one of
the big questions here is whether it
discredits the entire dossier that some
of these allegations that were in the
dossier were false or whether some of
the allegations were true the reason
that's important is because the FBI
investigation is at least in part
predicated on some of the allegations
inside the steel dossier apparently some
of them have actually been confirmed
meetings between from officials and
Russian sources for example but most of
them have not right like the P tape the
idea that Trump there was tape of Trump
hiring prostitutes to pee on a bed that
Obama and his wife slept on in Moscow or
something
but even people on the left are
beginning to recognize that this is a
problem for Hillary Clinton a New York
Times reporter named Nick Conte
Essaouira he said yesterday openly that
this situation looks sort of like the
reverse of the Trump junior Russia
meeting Donald Trump jr. and another
campaign officials meeting with the the
Kremlin connected Russian attorney we've
been reporting on that ostensibly to
gather dirt on on Hillary Clinton how is
this different from that it's kind of a
mirror image and look you know you know
parties engage in opposition research
all the time admittedly this is a
extreme example to hire former
intelligence agency but these firms like
fusion GPS are there because there is a
market for them companies and trade
associations pay them for this research
sometimes campaign performance kind of
research on their own I've gotten plenty
of research documents from the RNC and
their President Trump and I've gotten
research documents from the DNC under
Tom Perez right so the only question of
separation people are trying to say that
it's exactly like the Trump jr. thing
the question of separation is did the
Hillary Clinton campaign know that the
information was coming from the Russian
government did still know the
government is therefore compromised did
the FBI know all of that if all those
parties knew then you can actually make
the case that there was some sort of
collusion going on with the Russian
government if you can't then you're
saying that without any basis in
evidence so all I'm suggesting is that
we'd be objective about how we viewed
the situation what the evidence says and
what the evidence does not where Trump
is on more solid ground is where he
continues to rip on Hillary Clinton and
the and the Obama DOJ and FBI for
allowing the the uranium sale to Raza
Tom on in 2010 this was of course the
scandal in which Hillary Clinton was the
head of the State Department the State
Department gave the green light to the
Russian Atomic Energy Agency to pick up
20 percent of all US uranium supply at
the same time the FBI knew that the
Barossa tom was attempting to corrupt
truck drivers and engage in law breaking
inside the united states meanwhile the
Russian government was giving the
Clinton Foundation noodles of cash
here's Trump going off on that yesterday
I think the uranium sale to Russia
the way it was done so underhanded with
tremendous amounts of money being passed
I actually think that's Watergate modern
age he may be right I mean it's not good
I don't really like the Watergate
comparison generally because there is
actual evidence and hard proof but it's
not it's not great stuff no it is also
worth noting that everyone's hands look
a little bit dirty here there's a story
out today that Trump's data guru from
came originally Dhaka was reaching out
actively to the WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange WikiLeaks is largely assumed to
be a Russian cutout for help in locating
and publicizing 33,000 missing emails
from Hillary's private server again this
demonstrates willingness by Trump
officials to reach out to people
connected with Russia for information so
all of this is dirty all of this is ugly
the question is going to be how much of
it broke the law and how much of it
amounts to actual collusion with a
foreign government that has interests
that are opposite to those of the United
States okay time for some things I like
things I hate and then a very brief Big
Ideas so things I like today so as I
said over my vacation I read war and
peace it took a while
it was long it is quite good I was
rereading an essay that my father showed
me yesterday from commentary magazine
I'm pairing them to the author of the
essay on Anna Karenina Leo Tolstoy's
Anna Karenina and it really is a
fabulous essay explaining Tolstoy view
of human relationships and why it is
that Tolstoy is so gifted at getting
inside people's minds to express the joy
of living as opposed to Dostoevsky who
is who's very focused on sort of the
pain inherent in living the book Anna
Karenina is a fabulous book I remember
the first time I read Anna Karenina I
was I think 13 and it is it I loved it
then I love it now Levin who is one of
the main characters of the book he's
sort of a secondary character in a
certain sense because the Anna Karenina
does kind of love triangle with her
husband and Vronsky is the is the main
part of the book but Levin and his his
falling in love with and Mary and Kitty
presents the other part of the book
Levin's discovery of why life is at the
end of the book is one of the great
uplifting passages in all of world
literature Tolstoy is always more
uplifting than dusty husky Dostoevsky is
much more about looking at the fact that
all of us are fallen creatures and can
fall and toast
is about the fact that all of us have
the possibility for uplift and there's
sort of two sides of the same coin in
that sense Tolstoy was a very
conservative guy in certain ways and
when you read his books which are
largely about can you find fulfillment
in the sort of lasting love that comes
with marriage and that comes with
children and that comes with building a
life together as opposed to romantic
love a lot of people see Anna Karenina
as the Anna's some sort of proto
feminist figure a heroic proto feminist
figure hemmed in by the constraints of
society that's complete mystery of Anna
Karenina that is not what the book is
about the book is about why Anna is
doing something wrong and y11 is doing
something and y11 and Kitty are doing
the right thing right that's what the
book is about terrific book Anna
Karenina and not B not because of the
way the left interprets it too often
okay time for some things that I hate so
the thing I hate today
is the use of Ivy League college to
associated to dismiss everything so
yesterday President Trump was being you
know suggest it was suggested that he
was uncivil and he was unkind and
uncivil and so President Trump responded
this way don't understand I went to an
Ivy League college I was a nice student
I did very well I'm a very intelligent
person you know like the fact is I think
I really believe I think the press
creates a different image of Donald
Trump than the real the real person I'm
pretty sure that Trump creates his own
image I mean he's one of the most gifted
image makers in the history of American
life and by the idea that this this in
and of itself demonstrates a certain
lack of class if you think civility is
connected to intelligence you know
nothing either about civility or
intelligence really if you think
civility class decency these things are
connected to intelligence let me
introduce you to all the people that I
went to school with okay there are a lot
of people I went to school with very
high IQs I went to a junior high magnet
school or he had to have an IQ above you
know quote unquote genius-level IQ they
give you a basic IQ test to get into
this magnet school and I was at the very
low end of getting in and so there were
people there with IQs of 180 there were
people that were thy Q's of 170 and when
I remember thinking half these people
are going to end up in prison
and sure enough it turns out that some
of them are actually in prison
I can name a couple of moths out my head
the reason being that intelligence and
decency are not always aligned and so
for Trump's respond to a question about
civility and decency by saying I went to
an Ivy League college is pretty
ridiculous also by the way intelligent
people don't have to go around on a
daily basis expressing that they are
very smart people that's just not
something that they have to do generally
I know exciting out with a lot of very
intelligent people all the time Trump
but this is Trump's tech you know I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna fault him too
much on that because this is his deal he
also said yesterday he has one of the
great memories of all time right like
really this is what he said I was born
with a certain intellect the fact is you
have to be born and blessed with
something up here god help me by giving
me a certain brain it's this it's not my
salesmanship it's what this you know
that is the brain power I have like a
very very high aptitude I'm pretty good
at English I always did very nicely in
English we like I'm a smart person I'm
very good at English okay again yeah
this isn't gonna turn into a riff on
Donald Trump's intelligence level
suffice it to say I think his own
opinion of Zach he was probably inflated
but but he said he has one of the great
memories of all time again just showing
once again that intelligence and and
decency are not always aligned okay time
for the big idea so the big idea today
right by the way that was not again it's
not a specific urban Trump there are
people on the left you think the same
thing they think that because they live
in big cities and they're very smart
that this therefore confers some sort of
decency on them they're better people
because of this know being a decent
person means be acting decently not
being smart and reading and reading a
lot of navikev okay the big idea today
very quickly people have been using the
term trickle-down economics a lot in the
media recently that's because of the tax
cuts that have been proposed the idea
that people at the top of the of the
spectrum are gonna get a lot more of
their money back than people at the
bottom of the spectrum which makes sense
because they're paying a lot more of
their money into the government they say
this is trickle-down economics and what
do you think that those rich people are
just gonna trickle that money down to
other people no trickle-down economics
is a term that was not coined by the
right
it's a term coined by the left the idea
here is that the people at the top of
the income spectrum are the people most
likely to invest in new products and
services why because they don't have to
worry about that extra income going
toward feeding their families if you
have an excess of capital that excess of
Capital either goes into a bank where it
is lent out by the bank at risk to other
places that are innovating or the rich
people go and spend that money on new
innovations that make your life better
okay people who are spent as I've said
many many times the person who's earning
$40,000 a year and gets back eight
hundred dollars that's great that's
terrific but that $800 is not going to
create an iPhone Apple getting a getting
its money back is going to create an
iPhone and the reason for that is
because excess capital means investments
in new products and the greater the the
the greater the concentration of access
capital the greater the possibility of
that you know the the idea is not to
transfer wealth from the rich to the
from the poor to the rich or from the
rich to the poor the point is that
everybody should be able to invest in
the products they see fit
but the products that require the most
research and the most time and
expenditure are the ones that are gonna
change the most lives and so the idea
that we that trickle-down economics is
about some rich guys spending on a yacht
that's not really the suggestion the
suggestion instead is that rich people
having more of their own money back are
likely to put it into a bank which will
lend it out to other business projects
or they are more likely to invest it in
up-and-coming business projects because
they don't have to put dinner on the
table for their family okay we'll be
back here tomorrow for the mailbag i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]